hey this is damon labyrinth with wired
and today we're driving the all-new
Tesla Model S i'll buy it very briefly
the model behind us this is actually the
performance version it's got 21 inch
wheels with summer rubber and fitted
with this largest 85 kilowatt hour
battery pack it can make from zero to 60
in 4.4 seconds which is about a second
and a half faster than the standard
model with the same battery pack every
Tesla Model S comes standard with this
massive 17 inch touch screen display
it's basically the size of two iPads
stacked together this is powered by one
nvidia chip and then the dashboard which
is another reconfigurable display is
powered by another nvidia chip having
been in both the standard 85
kilowatt-hour version and this
performance model the the difference in
acceleration and braking is actually
really notable
you